what do you think the too much would go
on when you see now see the way that
I've set it out anyone want to suggest
something okay so there's a few things
going on right you can see there is an
expansion happy here I'm sorry yeah I'm
talk about this one so you know what
this one's a bit borderline are
depending on where you get it that could
either be one or two bucks because as
you said there is an expansion that
there's a collection of like terms but
you know because it's quite easy
expanding and relatively easy
locomotives that's why you might just
get away with what bar this one however
you've got to go for two do you see why
right there's quite a few things happy p
this like here let me just have to deal
with it this right here are lots going
on right keeps is going on like you've
got to be on see I can't got to put
these two fractions together and your
comment denominator to do that and I've
also got a watch out cuz I've got like
an x + a + worm they're both need to
grow as I change the fraction okay I'm
also what I'm looking for is recognition
that it's not just for instance I've
seen some people do this when they look
at they say all of this there's two
algebraic fractions there right as I
said I know what to do with two
algebraic fractions I'm going to cross
multiply right students will do this
okay now you'll get something at the end
that's like that looks like an algebraic
fraction except the reason why you can't
do this is because it's not an equation
right like you can't just multiply here
I said an equation is a balance thing
right so you can double one side and
double the other that's fine you can W
triple whatever you like but these are
actual numbers you can't just double or
triple however you please right so cross
multiplying is something which i'm
looking for students not to recognize
not to do okay so i would say there's
got to be at least a mark or for your
answer but prior to that i want some
demonstration of awaited that control
and i find it very difficult to imagine
like I couldn't do it without doing any
kind of working out so I'm expecting the
person in front of you your market has
also done some kind of working out if
they've got straight to hear that's okay
but I would wonder how many people are
this is one
before Eliza how many people have watch
out for this side do you notice right
this minus is negative applies to the
entire fraction so applies to the 7x I
think we've got that but it also applies
to that guy right so there's fractions
and then there's expanding kind of born
into the same question that's what makes
it more of a challenge okay but now that
you've seen it you will recognize the
next time so let me just rub this out of
the way because it's wrong okay so I'm
looking for basically so I think we'll
just give that one I'm looking for
somewhere in here for there to be one
and then i'll give that as a final
letter among scrolling down now again
I'd probably say this question is to
marks where do you think that your backs
are okay number one you've got to do the
substitution just going to put the
numbers in and near you probably didn't
need to write this if you wrote
something like that it's okay right the
second mark is for the approximation
right so excuse me a student could get
this and approximately correctly and
then still get one over to obviously
however if I did something like this I
just went to my calculator and then I
saw a number and then I just
approximated but if I approached late it
wrong you haven't demonstrated that
stuff you did before right so if that
approximation is wrong I don't get my
other verse to most does that make sense
you see why working out to any morning
question one of the marks could be high
so um just going back if what someone
done was written that down straight away
and it was correct you're probably going
on reward the full marks there oh the
the working out is kind of what a catch
if they didn't do it right so someone
has just said all of that just give them
the gym etiquette but the problem is if
someone says that goes all the way to
the end but is made an error and
no where the error is okay how'd you go
with the equation hands up if you've got
the equation right hands up straight a
decent number of your hands down but
there were still some struggles so you
can see my first it was to expand why
did I do that first I didn t have much
choice why not do it I've got to get
with rackets right also I mean I suppose
I could have divided by three but you
just introduced fractions earlier on I
do you see here my factions appears sort
of towards the end but you can't avoid
them whereas up here it's like 7 over 3
gross i don't want doing something for
you ok so therefore I expand first what
have I done on this line moves second
line a 90 degree I've added 3 to both
sides and then you can see interesting
dividing through this last step here
probably not like a hundred percent
necessary if someone finished on this
line I think we're going to give them
the mark for that but you should always
simplify where you can't it's always a
good idea to accounts yeah so I think
we're going to go one here for some kind
of expansion or otherwise like if you
divided through it still works it's just
icky and then I think we'll close off
there if they got 25 points it's great
hide in but if they ended at ten on 12
they've demonstrated all the important
things ok the royalties question I think
this one was reasonably straightforward
so you can see that are like I've
mentioned before I always go through and
highly important pieces could help to
get them in your head and then you're
just going to do this calculation will
just make this one mark I think I'm not
going to worry about if they were
approximated wrong unfortunately that
would be the total just doesn't get them
off because it's 94 it's not 93 okay so
um ya know they probably wouldn't get
too low because it's a it's a very
straightforward calculation your
calculator can take carriages and sets
dollars and cents those kinds of things
ah things we need to be really familiar
with so I think that's just going to be
one order yep
9 um let's see so yeah I don't think I'd
accept that because I mean I think
dinner calculator did you remember when
you do this did you get that number you
see it yeah I think it's kind of unusual
to round off to the nearest and says
five cents maybe but ten cents yeah also
you should have seen firm money question
to the nearest cities kind of the
default if they want something more
specific like to the new dollar or to
the nearest a hundred dollars or that
they will specify right so that was um
that was just the one mark sorry should
be there let's move on up